Sabine, Ezra, Grand Admiral Thrawn: The latest
episode of Ahsoka revolves around some of the
franchise's most popular characters —
and that's not necessarily a good thing.
"A long time ago, in a galaxy far, far away…"
Ahsoka's sixth episode is arguably the most
exciting installment in the series yet. The
adventure introduces a brand-new galaxy, a
bewitching planet with a mysterious backstory,
a few cutesy creatures that will
no doubt boost merch sales, and,
of course, Grand Admiral Thrawn himself.
And that's not to mention the long-awaited
reunion between Sabine Wren and Ezra
Bridger. However, this episode also
typifies one of the biggest problems with
the Star Wars franchise in recent years.
Namely: Ahsoka Tano is relegated to the
sidelines in Episode 6. She and Huyang
receive a courtesy scene at the beginning
of the episode, but the rest of the story
is dedicated to Sabine's quest to find Ezra.
There's no denying that Sabine has always been
determined to find her friend, but it's
been Ahsoka's mission for a long time,
too. Episode 6 robs her of her goal
— and in her own series, no less.
This isn't the first time that a Disney+
Star Wars series has made the main character
a sidekick in their own show. In fact, this
is becoming something of a recurring issue.
The Book of Boba Fett rubbed Star Wars
fans the wrong way in a number of ways.
The slow pacing, frequent repetition, and poor
character development are just some of the
criticisms that have been lobbied at the bounty
hunter's spin-off series. However, arguably the
biggest sin was making him a side character in no
fewer than two episodes of his own solo project.
Chapter 5 and Chapter 6 of The Book of
Boba Fett both see Boba take a backseat
to Din Djarin and Grogu; they're pretty much
the two best episodes in the entire series,
too. It's here that Grogu receives his
Jedi training courtesy of Luke Skywalker,
which is more significant to the greater narrative
than anything that happens in Boba's own journey.
But here's the thing: Din and Grogu
already have their own series. Giving
them such a prominent presence in The
Book of Boba Fett took a lot of shine
off a character who has been a fan favorite
since The Empire Strikes Back. Basically,
his first solo outing will go down in
history as a missed opportunity to give
him the focus he deserved, as well as the
series fans always wanted. Then again,
the characters who overshadowed him were actually
subjected to the same treatment in their own show.
"This is the way."
The Mandalorian started out as
a story about a wandering bounty
hunter. Din Djarin eventually takes on the
role of protector to the adorable Grogu,
and their relationship quickly becomes
the focus of the show. Unfortunately,
in Season 3, the main players get lost in the
shuffle as other characters take precedence.
The Book of Boba Fett is partly to blame for this.
The titular bounty hunter's series reunites Din
and his little green sidekick after they were
separated in The Mandalorian's second season,
and the resolution robs their own series of
an engaging storyline with stakes and drama.
The end result? Bo-Katan Kryze, of all
people, turns out to be the main character
in The Mandalorian Season 3. The show's
meatiest storyline chronicles her journey
to reunite the people of Mandalore —
which is an interesting arc for her,
but not for the characters this
show is supposed to be about.
Meanwhile, Din's quest for redemption among
his people is resolved in just a few episodes,
undermining his entire journey until
that point. It's clumsy storytelling,
and it's understandable why there are concerns
about Ahsoka experiencing similar issues.
It remains to be seen how the rest of
Ahsoka's first season will play out,
but the current signs suggest a danger
of her becoming the latest victim of the
franchise's sidekick trend. Sabine's journey
has arguably been the most interesting so far,
and Episode 6 positions her as the
potential star of the show moving forward.
Additionally, with a fan-favorite character like
Ezra back on the board, the upcoming episodes
will undoubtedly be dedicated to continuing his
story as well. But will that also come at the cost
of Ahsoka being given less to do? Episode 6 does
tease a future showdown between Ahsoka and Thrawn,
though it's likely that Ezra will also factor
into the final battle with the Grand Admiral
At this point, it's probably fair to
say that most of the Disney+ shows
exist to contribute to a larger overarching
story with many moving parts. That's fine,
of course — but many fans will no
doubt hope that they're able to
make these protagonists feel more
integral to their own adventures.